saturday morning the las vegas strip
will be filled with bikes it's a
memorial ride to honor a tragedy that
happened one year ago tomorrow in fact
marks one year since five cyclists were
killed by an impaired driver near
searchlight bianca holman live this
morning on las vegas boulevard with a
look ahead to this event bianca good
morning
good morning so cyclists and loved ones
of those five cyclists that were killed
want you to grab your bike and join them
out here on the las vegas boulevard they
want to use the event on saturday to
help educate people on what we all can
do to help prevent another deadly crash
of whether it's cyclists pedestrians or
even drivers so you may remember that it
was last december in 2020 a large group
of cyclists were riding near searchlight
with an escort vehicle an impaired truck
driver struck and killed five of those
cyclists it was a horrific event for the
cyclist community loved ones created a
ghost bike memorial right next to a
popular bike path an intersection near
charleston boulevard in the 215. this
year they want to continue to keep their
memory alive and raise awareness to both
drivers and cyclists
we've had senators and congressmen and
commissioners reach out asking even the
state what can we do how can we help and
they seem to be really paying attention
at this point and you know we've had
some safety initiatives with some of our
partners that have been very successful
so yeah we do feel we're making progress
so again the key is to educate folks
this saturday and also share the stories
of the lives of those five cyclists
being michael murray aaron ray
gerald knee deja
tom trogger and auxoy ahmed so those are
those five cyclists that were killed so
their families and friends will all be
out here on saturday we've got the
information on our screen right now so
it's saturday it starts at 6 45 they're
going to be gathering at the church that
is right behind the route 91 memorial
site
and they want to of course bring your
bike helmet and snacks if need be and
that ride is going to start at seven and
then of course there will be a police
escort we have all those details on our
website eight news now dot com bianca
holman live local now